I've noticed this that you know this is
just a thing with modern culture in
general sometimes where there's not only
just a piece of music but just a scene
from a movie or TV show that you know
when it first airs is very hard hitting
and is one of like the most culturally
let's say culturally impactful
scenes that have come out
um that's going to get memed on to the
point where you don't you start to not
take it seriously anymore you don't have
that same emotional response you
originally did when you first saw that
thing that was me with unravel bro like
oh my god dude that I hate the internet
for ruining that song for me I cannot
listen to that song anymore when I first
watched Google I was like damn TK
[__] bang a track amazing track
perfectly sets the time for toe Google
now every time I hear the chorus I'm
just like I just love it you could you
could hand me a like a picture of a
white background of like a blob slightly
bent at the top to the right and I think
I would immediately recognize it yeah I
wouldn't even need to see kaneki's
outline you just show me a black line
tilting slightly at the top and I play
that song and I'd be like I know the
stream do you know the one General one
scene I despise the fact that has been
ruined now because I it's it's one of my
favorite scenes but it is the one piece
is real
God damn it when when God when
Whitebeard said it it's such such it's
so powerful it's so powerful I know and
now it's been forever ruins now it's
been forever ruins you know every time
just can we get much higher
every iconic scene that means it's a
good if it gets memes that means it's a
good scene yeah yeah that means it
stayed in the in the in the brains of
people right yeah but not every [__]
Breaking Bad scene is still mean to this
day but his is have you ever like
re-watched not like watch the first time
but rewatched a scene that you know has
hit you originally uh but has been
reinterpreted with like meme culture uh
and you just can't take it seriously
anymore because I'm afraid to re-watch
one piece because that scene was like so
impactful for me and now I know that
when that scene comes along I cannot see
that scene without seeing whitebeard's
clock right there like right there it's
just right there it just just his fat
[__] coffee he says it and I'm like
[__] [__] I feel I'm gonna have that if
I ever rewatch Dragon Ball I'm gonna
have that exact same experience of when
I see that could you repeat that you're
gonna have to explain this people who
don't get that reference the what the
[__] because you're okay with this
[__] he has his [__] out but you can
only see like the cotton I'm like what
is this even in reference to when he
turns Ultra Instinct it's the first time
he turns Ultra Instinct and it's a
powerful scene in the show but now I
can't I can't see that scene anymore
we're just thinking of could you repeat
that it's [__] stupid I had I had
that exact same thing I'm I think I've
talked about this on trash days before
but the first time I watched invincible
uh because I'd seen so many [__]
memes about it right like it was mean to
[__] yeah yeah yeah yeah the mark one
and like you know pretty much all the
scenes from the last episode and I was
like all right fine you know these memes
have intrigued me I'm gonna and you know
you boys have been saying how good it
was so I'll give it a watch and I watch
it and I got to that last episode and
you know the scenes of the [__] think
Mark think like that scene came up and
I'm like does she think Mark it's not a
second thing okay whatever that's the
Mandela effect that's the Mandela effect
right there but I got to that scene and
I'm like okay I understand this is a
very powerful scene right yeah but it's
just been ruined for me because of all
the memes and I hate that one of the
shows like the boys the boys there's so
many memes oh yeah homelander oh yeah
yeah they're perfect
reaction images are like all over the
phone yeah exactly
um yeah I'm wondering because I haven't
re-watched Breaking Bad since it's like
a re-emergence of memes I wonder what it
would be like re-experiencing Breaking
Bad now I've watched it like a year ago
and it's it's still holds up
you should know how good it is by the
amount it still gets maimed but that's
the thing I should tell you how [__]
good but see this is a problem I'm just
satisfied with the memes now
like I'm just like I it's like I I love
all these memes even if I've never seen
the show and it's just great like I I'm
just satisfied with the memes I don't
have to watch this is insane that it's
still being memed it as much as it is
yeah this isn't like this in meme in
meme history we've never had something
means this hard yeah like it's it's so
true yeah I that [__] image of Walter
like they change all the time but
they're one now where it's Walter and
the car screaming no yeah
I saw one word it was a cyberpunk post
and they were like and the one of the
links was like CP and it was like it was
the reaction someone quote retweeted it
with Walter screaming no don't
abbreviate soap Hunter CP no don't do it
memes they're so good yeah or I guess
we're on the topic of memes uh people
need to stop [__] memeing films with
cameras I I don't know like they're like
the recently you've seen this where what
do you mean so I I because I'm really
really excited for to watch uh is it
enter the spite of us or into the spot
no the second spine the second
spider-verse film and I feel like a lot
of plot points of that have already been
ruined for me because people have posted
like cam rip memes and for some reason
YouTube has decided it's a really nice
uh it's you know I've obviously put
interest in it YouTubers just
recommended me a bunch of [__] and I'm
like okay I understand like memeing
stuff but like cameras really why are
people watching cameras come on come on
Mac come on guys come on you know no
that's not cool yeah I don't know why a
single person would ever watch a camera
but it's actually unbearable yeah I
think I would ride that you're just
ruining any film that you would want to
watch yeah come on man yeah but I don't
know yeah but back in the day I remember
I used to when I was kid oh yeah because
you didn't know any better so I was like
man I can watch the Miley Cyrus movie
Let's Go in one scene okay Miley Cyrus
that was back when I think you know
streaming even like 720p was like kind
of crazy yeah everything was normally
480. the 4x3 aspect yeah yeah yeah so it
was like you know you'd get normally all
the films will be ripped in 480p and it
was like well a camera
you may as well just throw another board
in the fire
it's already [__] yeah and now we're
like yeah now Apple has just announced
uh Apple Vision or whatever right yeah I
just quite a while ago but I mean yeah
it looked [__] weird I just saw the
Marcus Brownlee video on that uh
yesterday yeah
um of him like reviewing it and uh I
don't know what do you boys think about
it are we okay first are we sold on VR
or ar yet I don't know if I'm sold on it
yet you know what do you mean I don't
know because uh
uh so I've been trying out like some VR
like a little bit more recently not too
much just like surface level stuff you
know like stuff like VR chat and played
around with that a bit and I'm like
I don't know I get it but I cannot ever
see myself committing to it you know uh
it's just uncomfortable end of the day
it's just uncomfortable right I think um
it's hard to say because we don't know
where it's going to be in 10 years or 20
years I mean it looks promising uh but
it also looks dystopian as [__] yeah so
it's kind of like it reminds me of when
like Google Glass first came out yeah I
mean it makes you realize how far ahead
of the the curve Google Glass was so far
ahead of well what anything that it
should have been yeah um and it looked
good and you know Apple are generally I
I don't buy Apple products yeah but you
know they're pretty reliable with making
pretty Innovative stuff or it might be
an expensive piece of tech that you're
like cool this was fun never gonna use
this I mean it's three and a half Grand
like yeah yeah not the average person is
not going to be buying this okay but
here's here's the thing right here's the
thing because there's been like a lot of
porn game that's for sure I mean I mean
that I mean that already exists you know
we are better
in 4k there is one use for the new
athlete you can spend 3 500 to watch
porn in four like 8K people are great at
adopting new technology funny enough
they're the biggest innovators uh when
it comes to like digital media I feel
like if you want to see what updates
YouTube is gonna Implement in like two
years just go into PornHub and you're
like ah PornHub did this like two years
ago yeah right
they're on that VR game before YouTube
was yeah I don't know I feel like there
has or like there's there have been like
Tech in the past that has gotten a lot
of hype that has just like for one
reason or another like never caught on
right uh I think like the one uh one
that comes off of the top of my head uh
it's like Segways you know wait wait
wait wait wait wait okay okay I was not
expecting that yeah I was expecting 500
explain your thought process explain my
thought process uh you know when when
the Segway got announced there was a lot
of hype that it was going to
revolutionize Street travel you know
it's what yeah Americans will literally
do anything
and then you know look look uh look
where the Segway got now you know it
just turned out to be turned out to be a
a failure of Epic I mean it killed its
creators yeah yeah yeah I mean it killed
his creator died and you know there was
there's a there was a lot of hype around
let's say e scooter and you know it's
arguable whether they've taken on or you
know whether I mean it's taken on more
than the Segway that's for sure it does
take a normal you know I think the form
factor of the scooter helps a lot though
the Segway isn't huge but when you think
about storing yeah it's way more
manageable yeah also there's just
something about a Segway for the longest
time I looked at it and I'm just like
you just kind of look like a tool yeah
writing one and I can't explain why and
it always comes back to everyone okay
it's interesting why do you think that
do you think because you're like
t-posing basically
it's like no I must go to work goodbye
you look ridiculous yeah when you write
a Segway you look down yeah I mean I
hate the cool writing I I totally agree
with you
um because I do think you look dumb
writing a Segway
um but you know we've all written
Segways actually pretty fun uh
surprisingly actually super fun uh but
I'm wondering because my first
experiences with something like a Segway
was just seeing uh seeing it in like
dumb pieces of media like seeing it in a
random YouTube video as like a you know
to
um to parody like the nerd or something
like that or in like [__] pull Mart
or Paul like the mall cop [__] movie
that I can't remember
or something like that and I'm like okay
Segway that's dumb that's dumb and
stupid you know
um I think what was more dumb though was
like not even like those kinds of
Segways with the handles but the ones
that is just the feet yeah oh you know
you know those ones where you just like
step on it the hoverboards things like
which I don't know what a [__] name yeah
that's another one where I'm just like
you could be the the badass [__]
with like infinite res once you're on a
hoverboard you have lost all the risk
you just look like a tour writing yeah
so so the reason I bring these up like
like the hoverboard as well which is
just like you know I feel like went and
you know came and went through it was
kind of like a fad a trend you know and
I'm like both of these to me tried to
solve a problem that didn't really exist
you know it's it's it's like Segway
solved the problem of Transport for for
whoms you know well you know for more
cops yeah
I realize after you you know you you use
a Segway and I guess the inherent
abilities like a Segway has above other
I guess transport methods yeah indoors
it's pretty good in like spaces like
malls yeah yeah yeah yeah but outside of
that it's a bite of courses you know
that would be real be really good for
golfers golf carts golf carts
that's true that's true and then you
kind of realize oh wait e-bikes are just
better than Segways because it's more
stable you can have a basket yeah you
know it's more natural as well yeah
you're sitting down it's a lot more
comfortable yeah you kind of realize and
and there's a lot of infrastructure
already for bike parking yeah so you're
kind of like oh e-bikes are just a
better version a better version of uh
what Segways tried to be I guess yeah he
bikes are good I mean yeah you've ridden
e-bikes
um you know whenever I've I've driven on
my friends e-bikes as well they're very
very good yeah
um and uh you know okay so I guess going
back to like apple Vision okay looks
wise looks ridiculous all right you uh
the [__] the fact that you can see
the eyes on the other side just makes
you look like a [__] cyborg I'm like
if Apple can't make it look cool ain't
no one there ain't no way anyone's gonna
look cool
yeah yeah
but it's like because the way that they
do it is that like it's not actually the
eyes it's not like a transparent screen
where like you can just see the person's
eyes it's a reflection or I guess a an
image of what the inside camera views
your eyes at yeah it's been projected
onto it yeah so it just enlarges your
eyes
so you just look like an insect yeah
yeah sounds fun and uh you know I you
know the the biggest thing I thought and
uh because I haven't tried out the Apple
Vision yet none of us have obviously the
only only Marcus hasn't yeah we are not
um
yeah but like what's uh is like with ar
and like VR Tech in general like what uh
what problem are we trying to solve here
what are we I think it's like trying to
offer especially with ar it's like
trying to offer more ways to interact
with an environment or like let's say
you had like I don't know you could if
you were like a 3D modeler or an
architect right like it's like oh come
come to the architect office put on
these girls look right there we've got
this 3D design of this building you can
kind of interact with it it gives you
another layer of like kind of presenting
I'm sure that's what people said about
it but that's like okay what you
described is such a specific situation I
mean think about it with like a computer
back in the day they probably had the
same argument with that like yeah adding
up numbers that's so specific I'm not I
can add it just fine with the with the
[__] bead thing what are they called
the the what the Abacus yeah the Abacus
right here bro we don't need that like I
I think it's again with technology like
this I think it's more about like
trying to find a u-ship right away is
not the correct way of looking at
technology it's like let's make it let's
make the tool people will figure out how
to I guarantee like when it comes to the
Apple Vision it was probably just a
bunch of like Tech heads who like
watched Iron Man and saw Jarvis and was
just like that looks cool I wanna I
wanna do this yeah you know but I think
there is this like it's you know it's
also presumably if if this does work
because apparently it's just you clicks
like this right yeah that's way more
accessible in terms of
um technology than if you know what if
you're a person who has very limited
movement in your hands for some reason
yeah you know using a smartphone could
be difficult you know people use you
know some people who are quite disabled
have pens in their mouth or they have
some other solution or text-to-speech
whatever yeah there's always more ways
of of using technology acting with it
also uh I guess I mean the fact that you
could just have a display that is like
your entire Vision like if you could
watch a movie in 4k that sounds kind of
it's literally a HUD
you just have your entire Vision taken
out for it but again it's like how will
it actually work and I mean for me it's
like the comfort thing would I ever
choose to watch a movie in like with a
big [__] absolutely
I think it's like the death of Cinema
yeah yeah would I ever choose to watch
it probably not because even just
playing around in VR for like a few
hours I'm like I need to take this off
I'm like yeah I've tried watching a
movie on my VR headset because I was
like I was just curious I was just
curious I was like okay like they
[__] advertise that like you can
watch movies in VR and it's like you're
actually in the cinema I'm like all
right let me try this so I tried with my
VR headset the I have an Oculus too so I
traded with the Oculus too 30 minutes in
I'm just like I can't see anything
because the sweat is just like coming
over my eyes
is just burning from like staring at the
screen that's right here and I'm like I
don't think I'm gonna be doing that I
think also as well there's could be a
benefit in you know obviously right now
that price point is ridiculous yeah but
down the line it'll probably get cheaper
as as uh new technology comes out yes
yeah like if this could be like a
all-in-one replacement for a PC TV phone
even that could be quite promising and
it could give you know that technology
could be more accessible to people in a
lot of people I mean it's first
generation Tech right now it's more you
have to kind of figure it out from that
I personally it freaks me out and I'm
not a big fan of it but I think not on
kind of being against the idea of
progressing it is kind of
um I understood not helpful right and
they'll say yeah it's not helpful but I
guess I guess to play Devil's advocacy
as well to play Devil's Advocate uh like
one thing that I've learned I've come to
despise within the past five years is
the whole Tech bro culture you know like
bro like adopting Tech yo nfts crypto
this is new technology it's not about
the tools man it's not a fad mom I swear
yeah yeah so it's like because because
of this it's kind of like
giving me a more critical eye whenever a
new piece of tech gets announced to be
like do we actually need this well yeah
because it's like you know I is this
gonna be a fat like like kind of a
Viking Tech in like 2018 2019 was kind
of like becoming kind of trendy yeah you
know being up up to date yeah you know
and then nfts came out and Bitcoin blew
up and all that stuff and I was like oh
man
you go back to bullying
nfts made me actually think like there
are benefits to being yeah which is not
to say that Apple vision is on the same
level as nfts or like [__] crypto
whatever
um but you know it does make me think
could I ever see this you know I mean
Google Glasses like you said was way
ahead of its time but it still did not
take off right well no because it was it
was [__] it was too ahead of us
I I think people just don't want people
walking around with cameras on their
face the entire time yeah I think it
freaks people out like it looks like
you're a spy yeah yeah I mean you know I
know I do there's IRL stream so people
just look yeah I mean I'm I'm definitely
not going to be buying buying the Vision
Pro thing but like I am curious to see
where this Tech is going to go and again
with with tech more often than not the
first one is always by far [__] yeah
yeah just just wait for it yeah it'd be
fascinating to see like how it's gonna
evolve in like the next five ten years
right it's like affordable phones right
yeah no one [__] knew the foldable
phone but they're like it sounds kind of
cool that's an option and like right
like the first two generations I think
were kind of yeah and then I'm hoping
third fourth generation foldable phones
will actually be really affordable
smartphones yeah yeah okay uh what do
you think I mean um
that's the Boomer in me that's [__]
right there that's flip he's a foldable
phone it's different okay
I don't understand foldable phones
though I love the idea of having a phone
and then being able to turn it into like
a pseudo kind of tablet on the go
because I I have an iPad I don't use it
um I have not used it at once right
because I'm too lazy to carry it because
I'm sorry I'm like I just won't shut my
phone but I would love the idea of like
I'm watching and I'm like I'm like two
of these that'd be nice well I can't get
over because I've seen people who are
I've seen uh dinosaurs and I'm like I
can't get over the crease well that's
that's the idea right is that hopefully
in a generation or two the crease will
get better yeah yeah yeah but apparently
you just live with it yeah yeah you just
live with it I guess like mesothelium or
whatever that is in America that every
ad tells you about on TV the what what
you know what you know in America would
you put the TV on and it's like have you
or a loved one suffer from mesothelioma
call call the lawyer have you ever seen
these ads
all right and well there's that too but
every goddamn thing is like a lawyer ad
and it's like yeah it's like have you or
a loved one been affected by
mesothelioma let me see what the actual
word is I've never heard of that yes you
have before yes you have yes that
doesn't even sound like that sounds like
a mythical creature
mesothelioma a type of cancer that
develops in the lining that covers the
outer serves uh uh what trigger is it
yeah
I just remember this thing I want to
share with you guys you know
I don't know why I
I don't know I don't know where your
guide was that is yeah I mean uh oh no
because apparently you just live with it